all right so without
for the delay let me introduce our first
keynote of the day
Andy Terrell is
the president of num focus and has been
involved in the wider scientific Python
community since 2006 and a contributor
to a number of these open-source
projects right here
Andy received as computer science PhD at
the University of Chicago in 2010 he has
held research positions at the Argonne
National Lab Sandia National Lab
Institute of computational engineering
and Sciences at the University of Texas
Austin and the Texas Advanced Computer
Center computing Center in the industry
Andy has served as the lead developer at
Cove during its early stages where he
helped bring a record-breaking SanDisk
array to market Andy has also worked
with n thought and was part of the
founding team at Consumer Analytics
which is now and a condo so with that
please help me welcome Andy to the stage
[Applause]
awesome thanks everyone for sticking
sticking around on the last day and
showing up early I hope the the coffee
and bagels wakes everyone up because I
have some start off with some like deep
questions and the first one is just why
are you here so it's a question worth
repeating why did you take three days
out of your your regularly scheduled
program to come here what made you come
learn about our community that's been
two decades in the making right so a lot
of people come to PI data and say oh
it's a wonderful community it's a
community built on many years of toil
and sweat of our scientific brethren I
wanted to tell you a little bit about
that but before we get there what
brought you here today
was it a Kris Eric lecture that you've
learned about the tools and the
interesting things we do was it perhaps
some particular tutorial as you saw
maybe could reach out and think that
person for doing the work to show you
how that code words was it something
that you did at work did you innovate
create or
modify some piece of code that actually
helped someone
solve a problem or did you just have you
know want to get off work for three days
and do a low stress environment it's
cool to god did I see it so why not
focus this here we put it boldly in our
in our mission we're here to promote
sustainable high-level programming
languages because we believe that
high-level programming languages have an
outsize effect on what you're able to
accomplish so we put that in our
statement we want to sustain high level
programming languages open code
development we believe in open
development versus closed development
because without open development it's
very hard to share those results and
bring a diverse set of people's together
to learn and progress society and
finally we're here to promote
reproducible scientific research
reproducible because it's not science
without reproducibility you can quote me
on that and science because we believe
that scientific tools have outside
effect on the world at large
that's why num focus is here but some
say ask the question five times I'll
spare you I'm gonna answer it has five
times so I'll Baird ask again why are
you here
do you like jobs that every fortune 500
company in the world does that motivate
you there's every NASA mission for the
last decade
mosha promote motivate you to delivering
a billion page views a day in a
consistent reproducible manner motivate
you as building models understand
predict our amazing world empowering at
num focus we accomplish our mission
through four major channels first off
education programs everyone asked me
toques likes to talk about num focus and
how we do projects and everything else
fundamentally at the very beginning we
had decided num focus was an educational
platform it just so happens our
education is around open code second is
fiscal sponsorship all these projects
here exist because people give their
time energy talent and treasure and we
want to give back to them so we provided
them a way to take money for that time
talent treasure and continue to do their
programming and their projects to help
us build those cool new foundations we
run events like this one meetups we have
over I think 200 organizers all across
the world coming together to promote and
learn about these tools to help leaders
in the community make progress for our
society and finally but not least we
come together for common challenges to
help communicate with each other how
we're tackling the world's problems and
we do that with our data science
communities but there's many like us and
we want to participate and bring
people together to have a fruitful
conversation choose me to ask again why
are you here do you believe that
scientific discovery can unlock the cure
for cancer marius at flatiron health who
built carnivores does do you want to
stop humanitarian crises stop the
enslavement of marginalized people
across the globe Eric Scholes it marks
off research who uses our tools to find
victims of human trafficking does do you
want to warn victims of human a tional
disasters across the globe Col manly one
of our core Syfy developers does for the
most part the people who come together
and build these countless innovations
are here to build a better world and
while we get excited about the code
about the spelling of the libraries and
whether it's it starts with R or Julia
or Python this one it kind of brings
back to why we're here to build open
scientific codes
so I've asked you three times nobody
answered but I asked but I seriously
want to know everyone with the computer
in front of them please tweet send an
email let somebody know why are you here
it could just be that James asked or
Dave asked or Jim made a nice website or
Gina brought in a had a flier that you
liked or the somebody in the committee
came in it could be that you want to
learn a new tool
anything is fine we have thousands of
people of all our events and every
single one is a unique reason and unless
we collect these reasons and share them
with the world
people don't learn about our open
culture in our open community so as you
now please tell us why you're at hide it
and I would actually do it right now but
the AV system doesn't apparently I have
is having trouble earlier when ice
trying to switch so I'll assume that the
internet is buzzing and the the FOMO is
going out
so that's why we're here
I hope you've established why you're
here and for the rest of my seven and a
half hours I'd like to talk about the 50
projects but before we talk about the
project's I want to spend a few moments
talking about innovation so a lot of
people like to talk about sustaining
open-source communities and I think
that's good but really what drives those
open-source communities is innovation
and I want to talk about sustaining
innovation and I think that there's a
lot of things in innovation to unpack
and they come back and say how does our
how do we fit into that and how can we
progress forward as we go as we consider
that the topics so none focus has three
rules they're not an Isaac Asimov sort
of like kill the world type three rules
they're just three rules for our
projects and we try to come up with only
two but we kept darn it and a third one
keeps on coming on so the three rules
for being a part of our community
at least for a project to be officially
supported its first build for science
many people are many organizations many
open-source cultures are kind of built
for different reasons and those are all
great reasons but we came together as
scientists to build for science because
we felt that there wasn't a good enough
focus on the scientific coder from all
the other existing organizations and
because of that we only bring on
projects that are really built for
science I get people ask me all the time
why don't you bring on you know like
something like read the docs or the docs
is amazing project but it's not built
for science and where they came to us
we've luckily helped him find another
home to keep us focused on the
scientific programmer
and science happens everywhere we're not
academics we're not only in government
labs and companies backyards the
trenches and it's also true that other
people besides scientists use our codes
and we're grateful that they've taken
our codes and helped us find the bugs
and sometimes graciously giving us bug
reports sometimes angrily given us bug
reports we take those too but you know
we want others to use it anyway they
kind of any way they can the diversity
and use the repurposing of digital work
the recombination is what drives the
variety and innovation that has spurned
our community for the last 20 years the
second rule is be kind to each other
people say there's a lot of different
ways people have codes of conduct people
have governance documents about how
decisions are made but the end of the
day we want to work with people who want
to work with us it's not necessarily
about rules of exactly how you have to
say that but the Internet can be kind of
an unkind place and if that's what we're
going to gather we want to learn from
each other
if we want to be kind to each other and
third its lead open there's a lot of
different ways to write open-source
these days the way we choose is a
radical openness more than a license
more than just comments in public but
taking code from others being able to
allowing others to recombine your code
helping people use the best practices
and then open meaningful reviews those
are our three rules for our innovation
of our community and the community is
here it's open it's diverse it's in LA
it's in London it's an
Paris it's in New York it's in India we
just had pi day two days in New Delhi in
South America it is a global community
that you are a part of when you're part
of an ngon focus events and the three
rules are not new maybe not even
surprising but they are controversial
and you don't believe me just ask
yourself would gingka's Khan have ever
shown his plans for ransacking a city
maybe that's a little heavy-handed
taking an x86 chip could that have been
developed in an openly collaborative
fashion if you read the soul of a new
machine one of the best books of
developing companies of technology you
might come to the conclusion that no you
can't develop openly but we disagree and
we have the proof in the projects and
the innovations that you all have
brought to bear to show for this for
this culture and I have actually been
asked to talk about innovation a few
times and I always like to use the
analogy of of the first flight we see
here the Wright brothers and their first
flier immediately our eyes are drawn to
this wonderful contraption that was an
amazing feat of of two individuals and I
want to say turn your eye away from that
contraption and look more at the culture
of innovation that allowed their focus
the variety the failures and the
systematic repeatability that led to
that invention so what created the
innovative culture that led to the
invention I encourage you if you ever
have a chance to go to the Outer Banks
of North Carolina visit Kitty Hawk and
this was the innovation
the innovative environment at Kitty Hawk
a hill and a Shack wasn't a pristine
enterprise was a vaulted academic
lineage there's two brothers who lived
in a shack
who ate slept everything there during
those months that they were
experimenting they lived in this Shack
at the end of the hill so that when
their contraption failed they could pick
it up and try again with the small
modifications by moving to a place where
failure was easy and not and not
criticized or demeaning and being able
to focus on that innovation day-in
day-out they were able to do three to
three flights a day as opposed at the
current time age people were taking
weeks two months between each and it
flight the same story was repeated with
the gossamer flight the first human
powered flight where they built not just
the contraption because the contraption
eventually got built they built a system
for testing and repeating and failing
and learning I believe that that is what
our open culture has provided us an
innovative culture to learn together I
believe that the story the Wright
brothers is often told over and over
again in every business book go read
Pixar's book or how Google's works or
the magic of Amazon all of them talk
about building this innovation
environment but I don't know about you I
don't I'm not happy that so many of
these innovations only happen to a very
small portion of the population
so while the Wright brothers had the
affordances that let them go spend
months on a beach where there's goods
good weather for flying not everybody
gets to do that
and I believe innovation comes from
everywhere whether you're in the Middle
East
the African desert African villages or
just the bad parts of the subway which
I've been to all these places and the
bad parts the subway smell much worse so
if we want to believe in building an
innovation platform in a diverse
platform we need to really build it in a
way that's open to the world and that's
what's known focus means when we say
open sore
Co evils better science so to build that
sustainability that sustaining
environment what came out of it many
people are probably here because of
these projects but where do these
projects come from why are they here
what is the principles by which they
were developed sorry
hit by the animations oh my so I like to
talk about the different activities we
do and I usually gauge it in my life as
a researcher at a academic computing
center so first you start with a domain
model if you don't have a reason for
computing please stop wasting our
electricity we need it for other things
right so we almost always start with a
domain model it means finding someone's
domain experience I had the wonderful
experience of seeing hurricane sandy
outside my friend's front porch and
working with many oceanographers on
learning why hurricanes bring such a
huge tide
wave and how to predict who's going to
be submerged underwater then we have to
get the data the data wrangling is
probably where we spend all her time
right the joke great 90% getting data
10% look analyzing the data 10% modeling
data science I always like to show this
off this was a a NOAA
that's buoys with maybe the first
internet of things in the world you have
6,000 these things along the coast of
America that give these nice little
matplotlib plots seriously you go to
this website and no it's too small to
see but it's a matte pot lid plot that's
just a time series of up and down a buoy
you put 6,000 of those together and you
have a pretty good data system for it's
showing where water is going to be after
a hurricane worked so well they've
started putting when Indonesia and Japan
and many other places in the world to
understand tidal waves and how they work
built in the 80s and 90s before any of
things was a real thing but because of
Technology we're now able to expand it
and scale it throughout the world the
other aspect always kind of go to is
modeling everyone likes to think of data
science is modeling without with just
with with no model that's not true I'll
show you our modeling world in a bit
anybody know what these equations are
I'd like to ask that
NASA's near by somebody works on these
equations I'm sure to the Euler
equations old and tried and true and
they work wonderfully for you know
putting water in a box and seeing how a
wave works of course we don't have water
in a box we have it on the ocean and
there's a lot of other things going on
so the model is just a model just like
any of our models the fourth kind fourth
aspect of our work
usually comes to computation where big
machines sometimes small machines where
we have a machine somewhere that has to
compute this repeatable scientific
discovery and we have to we wrestle with
that there's probably another aspect
that people don't like to talk about but
getting your 20 computers to talk to
each other is somewhat of a challenge
sometimes but we all like to talk about
modeling and daily experience but the
job's not done anybody who's tried to
actually change somebody's mind knows
that you can't just stop at computing
the answer you have to visualize the
results here's a wonderful plot one the
John Hunter excellence and plotting
contest and I think 2013 for a friend of
mine an oceanographer and Kristen thing
showing the title that the the drift and
tides and causing a very particular very
small part of the world
I don't even remember where it was the
chart was able to elucidate what
actually was going on in this
oceanography issued like show the world
how to predict a little bit better in
that very small part of the world if I
share the story so the Jupiter and
ipython notebooks of won major awards
now because it produced a new way of
sharing your story a computational way
of sharing your story a way that anybody
can come in and recombine and change
that story
put it on major websites like github and
render it for anybody to see a small
idea there was just a modification of an
older idea notebooks have been around
80s the Atlantic had a great article
about it why for 40 years did this idea
just languish and we mostly tied to the
halls of academia through open core
development code development and
innovative ecosystem
we're able to take that idea but others
recombine that idea and spread it
throughout the world to where now see
I've seen CEOs pop up stupider notebooks
I've seen economist Nobel prize-winning
economist so as of a month ago or a few
weeks ago showing how Jupiter changed
his whole computational stack allowing
him to share code and go find those
economic theories to solve the world's
hunger problem or poverty problems or
whatever you goes after and of course my
favorite because I'm a geek is the tools
for building things and that's the part
that nobody ever wants to talk about at
least not at the the business level but
if we don't have them if we don't build
them the tools for building our tools we
can't accomplish the innovations we need
just like the Wright brothers built
their shed with their tools so they
could modify their coat their
contraption every day we've built our
tools to modify our code and recombine
our codes every day so I'd like to just
introduce you to some of these tools
there's 50 packages and all I don't
think I've seen the single person that
has all of them put together in a single
program but for the most part somebody
has part of some of these everywhere in
their codes so we have Cantera which
I've just using their sticker logos so
Cantera doing combustion of psychic bio
doing violin violin from attics helping
us find new drugs molecular dynamics
dynamics showing us the worlds of
protein folding q-tip which is this
funky quantum graph guy here doing
quantum computing son PI showing us the
inner workings of the Sun and helping
predict how solar activity affects the
earth a stroke I didn't helping redefine
how that's true astrophysicists compute
into a world which allows that
recombination econ arc which is a
toolset for economists to build economic
models in a way in a way that is
repeated reproducible how many people
remember that the Excel bug that caused
the world so many millions of dollars
it's a group that says let's come back
to that open scientific leadership and
show the world how to actually compute
in a repeatable way unit economics data
wrangling everybody probably knows numpy
and pandas there's a cornerstone of so
much innovation of our time but there's
a new thing X array we people heard of X
array yet few of you if you haven't
you're computing large arrays on the
cloud go check them out because they
found very quickly that the the
innovation and accessibility and
scalability of the cloud is great but it
does terrible things to our file systems
and we can't access that data nearly as
quickly as we used to
so we have to create new tools pie
tables that says using old tech older
technologies very efficiently a big
table and lots of memory and lots of
disk space dined a dynamic ray library
data retriever a way to manage all your
manage your data and and tag it and
understand how it flows are open SCI
which is a whole community of Oh open
packages for pulling down data and
manipulating and modifying data in the r
programming language they saw we're
having so much fun here in the Python
world the our world has joined us and in
Arkansas and many other fronts modeling
this is the part we all well maybe not
all of us but many of us like to talk
about right I can tell how many talks I
go to people want to talk about the one
little detail in there they're modeling
pipeline which is awesome but it's
always part of the bigger picture up at
the top and the we have jinsim natural
language processing for humans most
robots do my met natural language
processing but you know sometimes humans
do too was a joke you're supposed to
laugh
sorry scikit-learn so affiliated project
it's been defined the standard for how
to build interfaces and machine learning
algorithms it's always a tool I pull off
the shelf first rarely the tool I end up
using last but that's that's innovation
though allowing to an interface to
dictate how everybody talks to each
other is an innovation that's hard to
capture hard to price hard to put on the
economic value on but without it you
can't capture the value of the open
innovation that's their jump is a new
one from the Julia family of codes jill
is an excellent language everyone should
check it out jump is a multi
optimization library using many I guess
algorithms for interior point methods
and in many goes beyond the typical
convex optimization routines that you
see in many libraries and only possible
because of the very flexible nature of
julia the whole family of bayesian
analysis pi MC cubes stand pomegranate
we get to hear from the master later
today about Bayesian analysis and the
three libraries implementing his ideas
Shogun for very fast implementations of
the standard machine learning programs
stats models because R has a lot of
models that sci-fi didn't have and
we wanted to be able to capture it I
think skipper is gonna be here today
talking about statistics psychic image
because sometimes we're data's in images
and we're gonna pull them out again econ
arc for more economic modeling we have a
Sai PI which how many people actually
import scipy and use it some of you but
is the underpinning to love many of
these two of these programs without it
without the the combination of it and
the think on the beginning it was like
maybe 10 15 codes that it brought
interface to that were all developed in
the 70s and 80s it brings computing from
the dinosaur ages and Leeson computing
in the computing world every always
asked me like why is it so hard to
install everything I was like well you
know
so what sci-fi was written in 1966 by a
group of folks who were doing linear
algebra I mean they were good fine folks
but they didn't couldn't predict how our
computers were gonna work or how our
compilers are gonna work so we now have
a site by that kind of makes that easier
but if you want to go in into it it
takes a lot you learn a lot of history
Phoenix which is comes from the
computational mechanics world people
solving PDEs partial differential
equations for everything from flows of
of oceans to although they don't do much
ocean modeling but a biological flows
the heat flows to elasticity there was
even a movie made where that's some
rigid plastic thing that they that
Phoenix was able to help with so very
rich ecosystem modeling computation
because it's hard to compute all these
things at once Julia's a great language
just hit one point oh I think there was
a tutorial early on it - trying to beer
at rivals to the spark world and and
give native parallel computing to Python
these just like six lines of code and
your
running on hundreds of servers or so
they tell me simp I bring symbolic math
to our everyone's lives i Python an
interactive interactive pipe Python
interpreter I think once a friend of
mine said if you don't not using ipython
you're doing it wrong it's now evolved
and the Jupiter as we all know and love
I Python still there and it's still like
a great tool I was kind of crushed when
James didn't show ipython console in his
uh how to fix your code because it's got
a lot of amazing features for debugging
those terrible 50 lines 50,000 line
programs that nobody knows how to deal
with numbah putting code into LLVM and
running it even on the GPU making it
super fast scythe on the code that send
three lines you're able to speed up your
code very quickly to bring it down to
the C level for Python Tiano which
originally was more of just that
symbolic engine put together to produce
graphs has become the cornerstone of
deep learning that is like taking off
over the world and it's been recently
replaced by more competitive things on
the market but they're still they're
still going through their end of life
because innovation things rise and
things fall in Theano is a nice story of
a community that built the thing that
now there are many types of Tiana's that
exist visualizing the results everyone
knows matplotlib funny story I happen to
be responsible for DNS and its web
servers for almost all these projects
and one point matplotlib went down got a
phone call from Google I didn't even
know Google called people apparently
they do and so now if you if you search
for a matplotlib parameter you you'll
get a nice little pop up because our
website infrastructure wasn't you know
scalable enough for them it'll tell you
the arguments or at least it did for me
a few times I haven't seen it lately
so one of the most popular websites on
the planet apparently so popular Google
will call you if it goes down okay the
the savior of all of our time by writing
hundreds of lines of JavaScript hundreds
of thousands of lines of JavaScript so
we don't have to if you ever want to get
a dynamic plot in a web web browser go
check boquete out there's a great great
talk earlier yesterday about it -
bringing shiny to the Python world plot
Lee's done a really great job of
bringing sharing graphs online and now
they brought a new system that allows
you to put it all together in one web
application orange a tool for managing
all the models and visualizations mostly
around text mining but can use it for
many other things very big in Europe I
hear and whitie the possibly the worst
logo of all are stickers I love this
tool they visualize galaxies if you ever
gonna want to present let's just look up
YT like like tutorials and like they
have visualizations of billions of stars
and yet that's their 2d image but
there's got some really cool tricks and
they just want to grant recently they
able to index very large objects very
quickly and do modeling in in
three-dimensional space in ways that are
innovative and new many many of our
tools are leading the edge YT is no
exception
ignore the sticker logo Jupiter who here
doesn't know about Jupiter awesome
Jupiter is a tool that has changed the
way we do science it's changed the way
people communicate and it continues to
evolve and that another project
interacts that has come out to reduce
the barriers to running a Jupiter
notebook so that anybody you can click
and click on a program
their computer can open it up without
having to necessarily run a web server
it's also brought in the best designer
is to come up with nicer logos never
mind they don't have a word mark but
that's okay go check it out
interact how they've been doing very
cool things and have a lot of
visualization within the tool itself and
open journals because you can't publish
always your code easily you can't
publish your results easily people don't
always understand this controversial
idea of open code development and
innovation through the different aspects
of the data science story they only want
a few of the stories and so our
community started a whole set of
journals the Journal of open source
software and general of open source
education Joss and Jose all reviews done
openly on github and there's not really
a rejection there's just continued
review to help you improve so flipping
the entire scholarly academic world on
its head changing it from a a rejection
based promotion for self-promotion type
of culture to one of leadership and
opens open kindness and giving back to
each other
my final category and I'll stop boring
you with the explanation of every one of
these projects is the the tools to build
our tools straight in the middle
kondeh that wonderful tool that some
will say fixed pip others will say
pointed weaknesses to pip to make tip it
better but has become a tool that is
used throughout our our our ecosystem in
fact if you want to install the fastest
tensorflow
and still conda because it will install
mkl which is the fastest linear algebra
library that you're not going to be able
to install yourself I guarantee you I
tried it I have a PhD it's hard the Koch
secondo shared that knowledge and keep
it up to date
Conte affords the open-source set of
recipes because one problem with having
an open environment of digital
recombination and recreation is we have
a lot of packages I show the 50 here but
there's probably hundreds more that
under the hood and we have an open
community that can share those recipes
for building spider the ide that's been
around the block and lots of people
still love and use despite all the open
new hotness coming out and in the world
spider has been there for throughout the
ages
bringing say an ide that was built for
scientists and over here we have SPAC
how many people use supercomputers very
few if you ever use a supercomputer you
realize installing software on a
supercomputer is a lot harder than your
laptop SPAC solves that for you they do
a good job check them out the three of
you that I saw hands and Python XY
because installing on Windows used to be
a nightmare the windows folks have kind
of changed their their viewpoint of our
community and are now a very open member
to our our community but Python XY is a
tool that we wants everyone used and now
has perhaps used less but still there to
help people so that's our ecosystem
that's the whirlwind tour that this open
innovation has allowed us to create so
we have a few minutes left and I'd like
to tell you a little bit more
speculative like where we need to go how
do we build the next platform how do we
build what we're doing the pitch I give
to corporations is they have inherited a
huge amount of risk because they're
using our open platforms if they don't
give back if they don't build help us
build a community here's some of
graphics if you go to our website and
download our course perspective you'll
see a lot more details we take
matplotlib pandas and numpy
that represents hundred thousands of
lines of code and on the work of you
know five hundred different packages you
have maybe pandas for example as Tim
core developers only one of which is
paid 20 percent time 110 percent time
and the rest unpaid so num focus is here
to try to help build a funding mechanism
so we like to call funding quilt for
these people and we do that through our
events and our fundraising and our
corporations this is an old slide pie
dated 2017 I don't didn't have the
numbers this morning when I wrote the
slide Oh on that lie I wrote the slide
last year and I didn't update it sorry
but we have you know lash xx 16 we had
nine events I think this year were
upwards of 19 or something
hundreds of speakers thousands of
attendees hundreds of people coming
diversity scholarships reaching out to
the community and hundreds of thousands
of dollars going back to these projects
if the impact touches the entire world
we have meetups in five country or five
countries especially three continents
but sorry the didn't come out quite
right but eighty different groups and
this was in 2016 I'm not quite sure
we've just grown from there I skip this
slide but the the end of the day where
what are we doing to grow the programs
I've come together with all right after
summit and talked to people we have form
initiatives we're trying to kick off
community Road mapping helping all of
our projects build roadmaps so that they
can bring investment into the community
and the community can know where they're
going so that there is a a road going
forward and we can understand how to
move together we're looking at building
an academic Academy program that helps
people learn more about our codes and
get certified and and provide solutions
based upon our tools but looking at
cloud infrastructure services
the amazing tools that we use once you
get them set up once you're amazed it's
wonderful it's great but man is it hard
to get all these things working on a
cloud environment the first time I can
count my hands three or four companies
that they do it and then go and try to
sell that product for millions of
dollars
I like that product to exist for the
community in an open fashion and then
finally auditing people want to know
when those tools are being used they
want to know how they're being used they
want to know just like I wonder why you
are here you know why you're using our
tools
so in conclusion why'd you come here
share that with folks join us in our
innovation join us in our open culture
help us build tools the tools are needed
to solve these world's problems they're
needed to make your life better and meet
your creations and your jobs it's a
platform not just a bunch of tools it
takes more than code we need the
community to help us build that platform
together and then finally I say openness
changes the world that's something we
believe in a whole heartedly and I'm
focus and hope that you will help us in
that pursuit as well thank you very much
[Applause]
so if you have any questions please
raise your hand and I'll be passing the
microphone along
it is very nice to see an overview of
different programs that never forget is
support for me as I begin the joining
and I only see like two or three
libraries extensively but didn't see how
the entire ecosystem works how did you
get involved as a very beginner but with
some technical background so that's a
good question I hear a lot how do I get
involved and and and to be honest it's
it's it's somewhat challenging to answer
all the time
because we have so many people involved
at this point if you're a technical
background I think one of the coolest
thing you can do is just go and start
contributing to the code and now the
katrinak code doesn't necessarily mean
that you have to get a pull request
submitted it could very well be as
simple as you know next time you use
your library use the release version and
see if there's any bugs and if you find
a bug just go report it it's very hard
for an open community to tell what bugs
they put out because they don't have the
resources to stress tests like you might
do in an enterprise environment if you
want to start getting I think one of the
biggest challenges every developer has
in in these projects is being able to
review all the code coming in and so
going in just like looking at some code
on github and seeing what other people
are submitting at PRS and and asking why
or or maybe pointing out hey you made a
spelling mistake here it's not annoying
it helps because of any eye any updates
of that code helps it for everybody
then there's if you do want to get fully
involved there's dev guides I'm pretty
much every one of our our codes they'll
if you go there's a contributing file I
almost on every single one they have a
github repo there's if you go to github
and unfocus / gnome focus there's a list
of all our projects and where to get the
different mailing lists and things like
that and look at their future Ian's
guide and learn how to contribute to
them in a good way I don't think that
it's always necessary that you
contributed all the projects and or
maybe don't even buy it off too much go
find an easy bug first
and try to manage that last year we had
a documentation sprint for four pandas
and documentation is one of those things
it's just very challenging for us who we
manage because there's so many different
ways to document something if you find
some documentation fun kind of hard to
read first welcome to submit a pull
request but even submitting of writing a
blog post and saying hey here's
something I'm I learned by reading this
and then putting that the maintainer
said to help them understand how you
somebody might have misread something or
a better way to write something and the
documentation world as well we're
primary English based we'd like to
figure out a system for putting together
documentation for the rest of the world
so many different ways and as always
like events here come to your meetup
groups encourage others bring a friend
to the next Pi Day to LA which I believe
is happening next year okay I got
confirmation so many many different ways
and doesn't always have to be the code
remember is the whole ecosystem
so Wikipedia asks for money a lot is
that a model that you've considered yeah
and we do ask for money a lot join our
mailing list this is the first way send
this money I I will say that if you look
at our annual reports it actually breaks
down like where money comes from where
it goes a lot of our money comes from
these events our contributor donation
model we're like Wikipedia they they
have millions of users a day who visit a
website we have millions of users
visiting any one of our web properties
so it's not best strategy to just put my
face or Leah's face on on those websites
but we do have a donation drive every
year we have a sustaining membership
drives but the largest portion of our
money comes from it comes from grants
from governments to build these codes
for science thing comes from corporate
events like this one then it comes from
corporate donations so if you are in a
place where they look you know a
corporate entity who wants to give back
to reduce the risk of these tools
failing please contact Lea she will help
you get a donation from them and then
members kind of comes last they're last
in the amount of money we put it bring
in but there in my mind maybe first in
importance and so because of that every
person who donates it gets to vote on
our our board and participate in our
programs any way that we can
so obviously would really help if
companies gave money but I'm wondering
what other things companies could do
that would be really helpful like maybe
if the cloud providers made CI easier or
maintainer z' or whatever what's the
next most important thing after money so
I think the I've been talking with lots
of different cloud providers so we
actually so as you're just released
their CI CD system which looks amazing
and they've even made us a response
special account for our projects
talked with AWS and other cloud
providers to give us some of that CI CD
the one thing that we we can get compute
from some of these people but the hard
thing is actually getting the expertise
to run those systems I had a call with
many of the heads of these programs a
couple of weeks ago and they said how do
we engage this the DevOps community or
even the design community so well we're
very good at engaging scientists we're
not so good at design and DevOps and
those things and companies have those
people and if they do find people who'd
like to contribute to our ecosystem
we're in desperate need of those folks
so in-kind donations of people's time on
those things and we have different ways
that we can recognize that then also
like donate your venue probably they're
the biggest expense to any one of these
conferences the single most factor that
makes or breaks a PI data or Giulia con
or Jupiter con or any of these is a
venue cost a lot of big companies though
they have a room with 50 people you know
reach out to the the community and say
hey would you like to use our room so
you can so you can all meet and talk
about the code and teach others and
educate
thank you for your talk my question is
regarding what investments or vision you
have for the interpersonal skills that
are key to promoting as well as to
perhaps attracting various different
types of talent to collaborate with
engineers thank you for that quite
productive that list of people we have a
hard time engaging with we we do we have
a few programs so first one is there are
just discs or diversity and inclusion of
scientific computing which is a program
led by Gina hell for you isn't here as
PhD and Women's Studies from I believe
Harvard or some some one of those
Eastern schools so not the left coast
but the what's your name but so we have
the diverse so we have a diversity
program we also started doing a lot more
programs with Community Managers so our
open SCI and Jupiter both have community
managers and operations managers and
they actually we used to have a call
every week to like talk about how to
manage these codes I think that's kind
of gone up and down so if you get in
touch we can if your this is of interest
to you we can like hook you up with the
rest of our community who's tackling
some of these issues but the projects
I've put together one proposal to bring
together community managers for multiple
pieces of our projects and and the road
mapping is another side of that out of
that of like getting together to talk I
always tell people coding is a social
endeavor and we need to learn social
skills I mean a lot of us go to the
internet because to code in the early
days because we didn't want to talk to
people but hey what we were doing just
talking to people who don't see their
face that's trying it's no problem with
that but bringing in people who
understand how to talk to each other and
and guide communities is very important
and the slide I skipped was from a
famous informational scientist who
studies community management and so I
was going to talk about
time but thank you for your question
so I have a question I took off two days
of work to be at this event Monday and
Tuesday and on Wednesday I have to go
back to work and tell my boss and tell
my boss's boss and tell their boss what
I did what bullet points could I give
them to help move the needle for them
about why PI data and um focus are
important so I don't know thank you for
your question James
I appreciate the prompting James is a
director of the board so yeah he helps
keep me honest sometimes if you go to
the the desk you'll there's a pamphlet
if you have a boss who is interested in
helping the corporate sponsorship it
talks about how to become a corporate
sponsor there's also how the tutorials
and it talks about the needs we have
there's a whole sheet there with many of
the different ways we use the money and
the other day just kind of going back
and showing them I think the most
powerful thing is going back and showing
your boss and your team like the
different tools and different ideas that
you learned have a Lunch and Learn and
show off the presentations that people
gave alert show them how you can
innovate in the community some people
come here to learn who's available to be
hired some people come here to just
learn new tools and methods if you don't
tell your boss you don't tell your your
your colleagues or maybe your lab mates
or whoever you might go back to about
what we do then they won't learn and
come back next with us next year but if
you are in a position that you'd like to
get more involved at the corporate level
please talk to Leah and we have a
pamphlet that's more guided towards that
sort of literature
that oh I believe we're all done thank
you very much for bearing with me
[Applause]